thrilled to have here uh for the first
time this week uh a retiree we have not
had that uh but now we do
uh he is the longtime head coach of the
new orleans saints
super bowl winner and here care of zebra
technologies good to see you sean payton
that sounded a little
what the just the retiree you don't like
it do you but you sounded different did
it a little bit it sounds weird right
yeah i think so okay because you don't
strike me as one although
ron rivera was just here and he said for
me to tell you that you already looked
20 years younger is what he said i'll
take it he said tell sean i saw a
picture of him and he already looks 20
years i'll take it i'll take it i think
it's california no but i i obviously my
tongue is firmly planted in cheek but um
i i just
have to figure knowing the grind knowing
what the grind is cause it is that no
matter how much fun you may have at the
job yeah the fact that you could you
woke up the day after your press
conference and you probably didn't have
to find out what's going on at the
senior bowl and figure out what might be
on the draft board right and what's
going on for the new league year
and you could take some time off but you
knew that was always waiting for you
yeah i wonder what that was like yeah it
was different um
we did spend some time away
uh
the first thing is man i wanna i wanna
you know get my office cleared out yeah
for dennis yeah
you know i want to do that um i've got
to return this car i'm driving
at some point okay he says hey take it
as long as you need it and then right
away when he says that i'm thinking
is that a months is that a days is that
a week like how would you how would you
look at that crucial information as long
as you need it what would you say
give it back as soon as you can
[Laughter]
it's certainly inside 30 days yeah yeah
i would agree i would agree i would
agree inside 30 days i mean the
uncomfortable where they're like coach
where's the car at i think that's coming
after like four months or three months
so inside 30 days
right clock's ticking clock's ticking
yeah just uh normal things like that
relative to getting adjusted um
we traveled out here we're looking
around at uh maybe some possible places
to live out here yeah in l.a out here in
uh california okay okay very good so uh
each each little it's funny when you get
an uber here yeah
when you get in an uber here yeah and
you bring the topic up
they're all over the board
like yes last night was our you have to
live in pasadena uber okay
and
now on the way home or somewhere like in
somewhere today you know you're going to
get the manhattan beach uber yeah you
can't you know yes it's it's fascinating
to hear the uh
the reasons why you haven't gotten the
city of industry over again no i haven't
i don't think you're going to get into
that
no offense in the city of industry
all right i'm going to open the door
here and this is not a good door for me
what is your uber rating
sean payton that's a good uber rating do
you know what it is uh i have no idea i
know do you have your phone on you yeah
okay that's what you do no the phone um
you got the phone you got your phone
okay yeah you get the phone here you go
would you
just walk over here
just look at it it's totally fine
all right man this better be good
you seem like again if you're you're
you're a talker so it's good and i'm
sure it's going to wind up so they
actually rate us yes i know so here yeah
help me out here let me go
here we go this is fantastic
all right hold it and first of all you
text dennis allen you're not getting the
car back
go to hell
all right no rich can we tell coach why
we're bringing this up
contention here
yeah sean payton's uber rating is a
sterling 493.
is that out of uh is that a good rating
that's a great rating
i don't know
yes coach it's a good idea
honestly no look i'm not
when when i don't get a lot of four
nines out of fives
and i think part of that is like when
you coach in new orleans yes
yes
i'm sure who's not gonna give you that's
what i mean though can you can you i
need to look at this
i need to look at an out-of-state uber
rating that should be fair that's true
but in-state it's it's
i want to know what happened to the
point like there's point seven that
that's there's some meat left on the
bone i'm upset about you know i'm like
that kid that expects a perfect grade
oh all right put it up show sean payton
what my uber rating is and i have no i
have no idea
how the hell this is happening shawn at
four four five five
i think that
is
zebra if you could set that at four five
five for this year's run that would be
great
you're gonna run a four five five in the
40. it's just going to be at some point
by the 25-yard line
that's when i hit that
that's what we use these zebra chips for
we
put this chip
in your gear
and we do this now at the senior bowl we
do it at all the all-star games combine
players in the super bowl will have
these chips in their shoulder pads
and we chart all the information we need
yeah i had them in my i literally had
them in my suit and your gear but no
they put it they put it in one one year
was in my suit pocket and another year
now they're actually taping it onto my
damn shoulders of my of my uh of my and
it's this shirt it's the same
is when we swipe an item at the store
and it's zebra because of the barcodes
oh great that's right
so the little bar codes that you have on
every product that's in here yeah and
you guys have a lot yes we do
when you swipe
and gather the information that's
essentially what we're doing here so can
it help my uber rating because clearly i
don't know i mean i have been i have
been talking to everybody finding out
about their lives and just trying to i
think and it doesn't budge i don't know
what's there's a level to your humor
that
i think you've got to figure out how we
tone down like how we
how we just come off the because you're
it's it's witty it's quick thank you and
appreciate it it's it's outstanding
thank you i don't know that it's
appreciated in your words
[Music]
so i've got to get more common my in my
denominator is that what you're saying
sean well
the numbers tell us that
[Laughter]
numbers don't lie four five five there
it is what was the single star for after
that i don't know it's it's just like
saying just
hey no not stepping up just like trying
to dress it up like here at least to
give you one star i feel like that was
an atta boy
our players would get game balls
game balls and then we give out boys and
the atta boys are good job here on this
play oh my god yeah at the boy richard
thank you tj appreciate the atta boy
i've got sean payton your care of zebra
technologies here on the rich eisen show
okay so when did you start thinking that
you know maybe i need to step away a
little bit towards the end of the season
um
you know it was a difficult season
obviously everyone in the league went
through another year of covid uh
and for some time for i would say
probably a little bit more challenging
this past season than the year before we
lost more players
shoot we played the dolphins
in a game where there were 23 roster
players out in one game
i met two players in the locker room on
game day they were getting fitted for
their gear
and were playing that night
and they had arrived on a flight
and uh wow
so that was unique but i i think
probably during the course of the season
um man
we had one of those teams it was
it was cool to be a part of one nine
games and
you know had a lot of uh
challenges adversity uh and came close
to getting in the playoffs you know we
needed the rams to beat san francisco
right at the end there and we played the
falcons at the very same time and we're
winning that game we're getting an
update the rams are up 17 nothing
uh 49ers are moving back and by the time
our game ended we went into the locker
room and on the tvs throughout the
locker room was overtime
and it's the first time where
you know you come off the field with a
win
and then all of a sudden
the team that we needed to win didn't
win
and it was like deflating and that's how
the season ended it's the first time
that's ever happened it was that was
different right so put it all together
you're like now it's time yeah and
and
i went in had had some pretty good
visits with mickey and then mrs benson
our owner was fantastic she
she said take some time away and uh
we did that and came back and
i think this i think it's all i say this
it's a lot easier to get fired
than to leave no way yeah because when
you leave
everyone wants to know why
when you get fired it's like hey you
know
it's obvious yeah thank you
we appreciate you and we wish you well
you know when you when you leave it's um
especially after that long
um
you know it's it's challenging people
like you know he's leaving and and
rarely does the coach get to choose well
i mean it was also a journey that i was
very pleased and honored and thrilled to
have pretty much had a front row seat
you know i was there on the monday night
absolutely you know when a first game
when you first came back and you know
steve gleason with a moment that's now
appropriately captured uh with a statue
in front of the building i'm getting
goosebumps just even literally talking
about it yeah uh i was there the night
you won your super bowl and you came by
the set afterwards
and i extended my hand to shake it uh
your hand and you slapped it so hard i
could not feel from my elbow down the
entire interview though i got a blue
rating
yes you did i got like a three you got
you got it no we were giving you all
sorts of stars uh you know i was there
for that uh i have been there pretty
much every step of the way covering what
you're doing and then seeing you you
know in your press conference and you
know um and you talking about it and
then continuing to talk about it and
then talking about it some more i blew
off two zooms that i had set up you know
you weren't the only one out of work
that day sean you know but i i was like
okay i got to keep hearing everything
that you're saying because you were so
you know emotional about it giving out
baked goods like you know you're you
know mrs benson
that's fantastic a friend of mine said
last year he said hey your next job is
premier league soccer
and and it was like the day of the press
conference and you really when you're
going to talk like that you want to
disappear and just kind of gather your
thoughts right and i'm like
kevin you know my assistant was great
and he went out and got me some you know
some biscuits yeah yeah that's one thing
i've never been able to do is uh
yeah
it was um
i i struggled with
do you just release a statement do you
just do a video and and i thought you
know
for me it's always easier to answer
questions and and
and really answer until there aren't any
questions and
honestly the night before you're google
searching you know how do you not get
emotional during a speech there's
there's techniques that they can teach
you you know whether you they want you
to yawn squeeze a ball drink water
there's certain things
and so i had the water and it was going
pretty smooth and uh
question by question everything was good
and then it came right at the end where
i said are there any more questions
[Music]
and it was silence
and it was like that moment in the
truman show where it was like good
afternoon good evening and good night
right and that's when it was difficult
and it hits it yeah the neat thing
though for you sean is that you could do
really whatever you want i mean
you know i know i can say that you know
if you want to say it fine but you
really could you know if you want to get
in the media i'm sure people are you
know you even said it you know i i think
i want to and everyone had assumed
that well he's got this lined up this
lined up and so right up in even the day
before i'd call don you know a guy i
work with for a number of years hey don
of any of these people reached out to us
and he said no but i'm sure someone will
and uh
yeah that day
and i said it um i don't know what's
next and and it's a little uncomfortable
but that's okay
okay so you do want to try media yeah
okay yeah absolutely what do you want to
call games you want to do studio i don't
know
that question the other day was asked in
an interview and i really just said hey
wherever you see wherever you think i'm
better at okay um
i'm not married to any one spot right
you know really right um
so it's kind of exciting there was that
moment all right two days ago and and it
doesn't we don't have to talk about who
where the the uber driver drops me off
in front of the studio
all the time okay and and uh
and i that was probably where the little
ding came from i was outside louisiana i
didn't get the same
but he dropped me off and i sat there
and
here i am going in and i felt like man
it has been a long time since i felt
like you know i've got this like new
little jacket on and slacks yeah and uh
here we go and and went in and visited
with with a group that um
that was good okay that's a good feeling
okay good very good and if you you know
uh to over your right shoulder is a
die-hard cowboy fan who's been literally
staring at you coach this entire time
you know
honestly just it's it's making me
uncomfortable tj you know like i'm
really into this interview honestly i
don't know if we need some sort of
restraining order it's a good thing
you've got that velvet rope between you
and sean payton and you hear all these
rumors i'm sure quite a bit i mean on
the on the very end of it the last week
um
we took out kind of a neat front page ad
thanking the city it was just a picture
it was awesome um yeah then there was a
little mardi gras in there it's been a
great ride we'll see on the neutral
ground and most people wouldn't know
that that's like the median or
when you ride in a mardi gras parade
you'll tell somebody i'm going to be on
the neutral ground side of the float
which would be towards the inner part of
the street or i'm going to be on the
sidewalk or passenger side
so see on the neutral ground and then
it's fun you read the responses and and
that was it was kind of you know
appropriate and there's one guy down
there says coach that that's all good
but if you end up in dallas this will be
kindling
for our fire in the evenings
so there's been that um not love hate
but that
that fear because i worked in dallas for
three years prior to coming to new
orleans right and so
it wasn't until 10 11 years where it
kind of went away like when are you
going back there or you're not going
back there
um
but no listen i appreciate you and i
kind of felt this same
like heat also okay okay a little bit i
felt i felt it over your right shoulder
but i have no idea
could you tell me who's who sent that
kindling tweet because i had no idea
jerry jones had a burner account hey i
gotta check that out i have no idea you
know
i'd love you love you sean uh on twitter
um
so what about coaching again when do you
think you might get that you know um
what do you think about that
it certainly doesn't feel like
retirement it's just really a change i'd
like to see uh
um
i'd like to see how
how well i can do with this
because i think if i can do well with
this i'll live longer the tv thing yeah
than coaching it's just there's a grind
to the coaching there's a grind of the
coaching and but i've seen so many
coaches go from your position to
television it never leaves you mad it
never leaves you i see
mariucci on the sidelines he's got his
hands on his hips and he'll go right up
to the right and hit him right on that
right on the hip you know his hands on
his knees and go right what are you
seeing out there like and it's just like
i'm like mooch you don't have a
challenge flag in your pocket
you know what i'm saying but i felt that
when we had a game this year against
tampa where i had coveted and so i was
home watching
and like you're throwing stuff at the tv
screen and yelling at dennis or yelling
at whoever it'll never leave you yeah i
can see that um
but
yeah i think that in order to do
something really well that you want to
dive all into it and i'm anxious to do
that relative to television okay and
we'll see how it goes from there and are
you going to be like one president to
the other leaving a note for dennis
allen in the office yeah leave like you
know like one president does after
leaving office leaves a notebook i
cleaned it real good
um
here's my here's my gift to him yes is
it's got a nice you know bathroom in it
and it's a new office that was built a
few years ago and the shower has let's
say a normal shower pressure yes um and
i had met a guy that had gotten me this
unique shower head like you see on
seinfeld my gift my gift to him
he's going to be blown away
i'm telling you he is going to be like
the best thing he's going to in his
first day if someone really said what
was the biggest thing that you felt like
your first day was like at the office
he's going to say the water pressure
like the head coach had better water
pressure than everyone else in the
building because you're the head coach
you know how to do it i love it so again
zebra technologies has been the official
on-player tracking provider for the nfl
for the last eight seasons powering
next-gen stats they have been tracking
my run for the last they're the ones a
couple years i think for sure they're
the ones and it's been awesome uh
information well the information
unfortunately hasn't been awesome but it
is what it is as they say for me
um and how how do you use that i mean
how does this usable for you you let's
start with
my initial
um use as a coach for us as an
organization was training camp and
you know when you say hey let's back off
practice today what does that actually
mean and we're able to measure we were
able to and we still do measure
um
you know how far player travels during
practice how far he runs
how much running is he doing compared to
walking um and so we can actually put
some some clear numbers as to what type
of practice it was relative to soft
tissue injuries right um and if there's
some outliers you know one day we saw a
brandon cook's number of eight miles
relative to the rest of the receivers at
six
how did that happen and and then do we
want to make sure we're watching hey his
warm up or
um so outliers help us there um
soft tissue then
performance when we're
well take these bowl games for instance
and we're going to watch the senior bowl
and we're going to try to locate uh db
you know we used to have to look at the
hey he's the one with the white sock
pulled up he's the one with the towel
all of it now is just
like
your music you know give me
the snaps of bill smith and then boom
they all show up because he's got his
own
uh device
so that's that's made it very efficient
uh in season us being able to sort
through where players are lining up most
of the time
um when you guys watch the game and we
see travel 22 miles an hour that's fine
um but also how many times he's been on
the field and he's been in the slot
there's things that just save you
time and it makes it a little bit more
efficient love it and then eventually
eventually
they're in the footballs already but
when the ball you know goes out of
bounds on the punt
in the air so we're not going to just
get some guy like this that's my
favorite like every time i see the ref
spot the ball on a punt i think of if
you ever see the prices right the
yodeler that goes up the no question you
know the cliff hanger game it just feels
like you know they should use that
cliffhanger music as the guy just goes
straight up yeah and then he says stop
and it's just yeah it's like the price
is right 50 yards away
i kind of think that's the angle
thank you very much that's what it is
thank you mike appreciate that that
would be good don't you think that'd be
good
that's what everyone is thinking in
their minds when this takes place like
that's the music we're thinking about
right when when we're trying to when we
watch them make that
incremental decision as to the ball's
right here on the 23. are we going to
get this to see if they we break
supplies
it's coming it's coming there's certain
things no one wants to get rid of the
chain the chain thing is pretty cool
because look there is some drama to when
the guy puts his thumb on the yard line
and then that's not going away that's
pretty cool and then they
yeah right there yeah yeah there is some
drama as to where is it going yeah
that's a network we're keeping that okay
okay the flag that we throw yeah is a
red hanky with an ounce of sand and two
rubber bands okay wrapped around that
ounce of sand yeah yeah
and and so that there's drama to that
that's drama but this punk that goes
out of bounds like on a plane yeah
yeah we can fix that yeah we don't need
the drama of the guy going down the
sideline again like you know and if
we're gonna let's let's listen to the
yoder then
that would be good that would be good i
appreciate that and so uh i guess
yeah it's information forever and it's
no different than the information when
we're when we're sliding things across
the
the counter at an auto parts star store
you know we're we're
we're
we're tracking
uh product
and we're being more efficient with it
so that's the zebra logo really it's the
it's the barcode all right so i'm sure i
think dan did this to you after you
retired and you went on his show um
giving you the the shot at being part of
the paparazzi ever so i'll have you give
you the opportunity to break down super
bowl 56 who do you think wins this game
yeah sure peyton there's a there's a
cincinnati tie for me because i'd
coached at miami ohio for two years and
and the bengals always allowed us to
come watch practice
um
i i just feel feel like i've gotten to
know that family mike katie and those
guys um the skyline chili the montgomery
and ribs
the great
western person yeah the ice cream oh
sure yeah um
but i i think this is going to be a
tough one for them i think the rams uh
if i were picking i would pick
los angeles um
but i i
like everyone else we're rooting for a
good game and leading up to this game
everything has been amazing
these these games that we've seen last
two weekends
and then certainly
you know divisional is always the best
weekend of football they say because you
get those four games
and then the championship weekend uh
hopefully this will be a great game um
and you've you've got you know two real
good teams that are playing well yeah i
know and obviously aaron donald up front
and that's the potential uh fault line
for the bengals yeah absolutely but
burro i mean you gotta love his swag i
mean
moxie right you must in particular love
his unbelievable i mean you know what i
mean so i i he looks when he takes his
helmet off and he's got like the hair he
looks like a peaky blinder yeah right
sure he's got that thing just got that
look like
yeah he's getting ready to cut your
throat yeah i know
yeah joe peeky
where's everybody's trying to find a
nickname for him that's him sean payton
thank you sir let's stay in touch at
sean payton on twitter zebra
technologies everybody should know more
about that you're the best man thanks
for coming in thank you all we got to
chump in here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here